all right Tara and this one rocky said a
mountaintop
he gets swatted by the monster tail he
falls tumbles and rolls and pulls up
another ledge falls another bunch of
bunch of feet and then crashes alright
watch my hands i watch you here comes
the perfect my name is Tara Strong and
I'm mostly known for my animation career
I'm the voice of timmy turner from The
Fairly OddParents Raven from Teen Titans
Azarath metrion zinthos
originally I was Batgirl alongside Mark
Hamill and Kevin Conroy I've had a
really fun career and that was one tough
montage so I knew to me had to be happy
mischievous silly on a nerdy oh it's
very very adventurous bubbles had this
weird way of pronouncing things like oh
like I don't know why it goes Elly like
that but yeah the time I booked Rugrats
I just got off a plane with a screaming
baby and I'm like that's the cry that
I'm doing and most of Dill's lines were
in the stage directions so I'd be like
okay
and I was like my lines I remember at
the session we had to stop tape and I'm
thinking something's wrong and they said
Terra there's a new mom in the studio
and you're making her lactate and you
guys say I'm not funny but seriously
this will be extremely painful in the
case of Raven while I was doing the
audition it was similar to my own voice
and I thought just this idea dava's
weird got a little role every time she
says anything as soon as I started doing
this I saw the people in the booth kind
of look at each other and went that's
Raven Robin stop Batgirl was me like
it's the only voice I do that's my own
voice that was Batgirl Bullwinkle it's
like that classic story the line and the
mouse that were ripping off when your
voice acting you have to tap into the
ability to make something believable
without it being there it's a completely
different art form than on-camera you
have to let the audience feel what it's
like to fall off a cliff without there
actually being a cliff there you gotta
have to be willing to play around and
not afraid to look silly and then once
you create a character in my experience
they like live up in my brain and
they're just ready to come down when
it's our turn so I don't confuse them
they all are their own entity basically
I'm a crazy person so I just need a long
scream as you just keep going
[Music]
we need we need the store garbage bags
oh yeah Rajinikanth [ __ ]
[Music]